Let's say the United
States economy
is going into a
recession or maybe
even worse than a recession.
And you are the Chairman
of the Federal Reserve
and you need to do
something about it.
Well, the first
thing you would do
is that you would lower
the federal funds rate.
And that's the rate that banks
lend to each other overnight.
And the way that you lower
it, if the banks don't do it
on their own after you
say you want to lower it,
is that you print money
as the Federal Reserve.
And you use it to buy usually
short-term treasury securities.
And then that money
gets deposited in banks.
So the demand for
reserves, because that's
what these things are, the
demand for reserves goes down,
supply goes up, and the federal
funds rate should go down.
But what happens if
you keep doing this
and you keep lowering the
federal funds rate all the way
down so that the
overnight borrowing
rate is approximately 0%?
What do you do then
if the economy still
looks like it's in
a bit of a tailspin?
Well you could
still print money,
but using that money
to buy short-term debt
won't help any
because you're not
going to lower the short-term
overnight interbank interest
rate anymore.
So you can go out
and buy other things.
And those other things can
be longer term treasuries
or it could be other
types of securities.
You could buy
mortgage-backed securities.
You could buy commercial debt.
And this idea of printing money,
not just for target interest
rate, but essentially, to get
that money into circulation
and maybe to affect other
parts of the market,
this is called
quantitative easing.
And in Bernanke's mind, although
that's exactly what he's doing,
he's printing money
to buy other things
than what the Fed traditionally
does when he cares
about the overnight
borrowing rate,
he calls it, not necessary
quantitative easing,
but credit easing.
And in his mind, even
though mechanically they
are the same thing, in
his mind, he saying, look,
I'm printing this money not
just for the sake of printing
the money and putting
it into circulation,
I'm printing money so that I
can buy particular assets where
it seems like there might be a
log jam in the credit markets.
Because with just printing
money and buying government
securities, maybe the interest
rates on government debt
goes down, but maybe
because of panic or crisis,
interest or the prices on these
things don't behave properly.
So in order to fix that, credit
easing, in the Bernanke sense,
would be to go out and
buy this type of asset.